ماي تاون
او قيمه الرفض
بي 4
هل في اي احد في القاعه اليوم تم رفضه
خليني اقول لكم على قصه بسيطه
المسرح هذا لو مكان كبير في قلبي
محاضرات
[موسيقى]
قدمت فيه مؤتمرات
حضرت في دورات وورش عمل
حضرت في اجتماعات على جميع المستويات
لكن وقفت اليوم احساسها جدا مختلف
وقفت اليوم
رجعتني الى 15 سنه للخلف
اول ما تخرج من درجه البكالوريا قبل 15
سنه انجليزي
وكانت واحده من متطلبات الملاكيلات جيناتك
انه انا واحده متطلبات ماجستير انه انا
ايهاب
كان لازم اقدم توك ان فرونت اوف 50 نيتف
انجلش
ومن هنا بدات
تخصص يدور على تخصص ما في
فرزنتيشن
طبعا
ارجع وما بدي اكمل وبارجع السعوديه
وكانت مدينه مشهوره بالفلاط والفيضانات
فقلت ان شاء الله يجي فيضاره تغرق الجامعه
مين اللي ياخذ دي انا انا طول عمري
الكلمه هذه
كان لها اثر كبير علي خلاني اقدر اقدم
اشتغلت على نفسي
وخلاني اوقف اليوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ان زيتون
قررت انه انا بدي اعمل الدكتوره في تخصص
المراكشي
جروب في نفس الجامعه
ام سوري
يو ارنا الزيتون
حصلت على الدرع
[تصفيق]
طبعا يعني
رساله لكم رجاء لا احد يقول دكتور
اخلاصكشن هدف اليوم
لا احد يرسم في ماده لا احد ينحرم في ماده
تخصص احد يرسم فوزي يقول دكتور
انا دائما في مكتبي بدون طلاب
الدكتوره انا
تخصص دكتور انا ما عندي اختبار الهيئه
فاكون انا
مستغربين دكتوره خلص ليش بتضحك يعني
الموضوع ما يضحك لكن انا اكون
بعد مرور اعوام ستدرك ان الله حين منع عنك
ما كنت تحبه وتلحها عليه لم يكن الا
ليعوضك باجمل مما مضى ليرضيك ويرضيك
واتمنى اني اكون وصلت لكم رساله لكم
[تصفيق]